foreign
Sacramento hi Christy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
um so me and my husband are new to the
show we just started watching it this
month and we just started babysit too
but my husband
wants to wait to pay off our student
debt by to hear what the government says
um but I want to just put it all in with
our debt snowball I was wondering if you
can give me some advice on how to talk
to him about that
Sweet It Is
he still believes they're gonna do it
that's so sweet
I mean
oh how much of how much student loans do
you have
of together it's 14 000.
did you sign for the loans
this is what I that's what I would say
to him I'd say did we sign for these
loans let's pay them off
yeah
um here
there's a high correlation
between people's ability to build a
wealth and their
belief that their Destiny is in their
hands not the governments
very few next to no people next to
nothing next to zero of the millionaires
that we have interviewed over 30 years
got there believing that the government
was going to be a blessing to them they
didn't wait on the government to provide
Prosperity
um instead they left the cave killed
something and Drug it home and made
their own way they got the machete out
and went through the jungle
and so
um
to the extent that
anyone your husband you me believes that
the government is our source of
prosperity it slows down our energy
level to go into the marketplace and win
on our own of our own dignity and our
own energy
and that's the real tragedy of
the uh of the Biden Administration
dangling this carrot because most of us
know that they're not ever really gonna
do it
um it's PR it's not gonna happen it's
been a political Ploy from the start
um I don't believe it's going to happen
it may happen but I'll I'll have to be
on here going I was wrong and that's
happened before I've been wrong before
um Christy but uh I um
there is something inside of you the the
type of person and it's a decision it's
not a character uh flaw it's a decision
that you can make differently the type
of person that says I'm going to make my
own way in this world the type of person
that says I signed for those loans I
have an Integrity issue with not paying
back money I owe when I'm able to
and I'm capable of it uh those type
those two things that are decisions in
your character are leading indicators
for your long-term ability to build
wealth and so I would ask
um anyone out there including you guys
Christian I appreciate the call I'm not
picking on your husband I'm not saying
he's a bad guy uh I'm just saying he's
naive number one it's probably not going
to happen in my opinion uh number two I
would adopt the character qualities of
integrity and of agency of the agency
meaning the sense of I control my own
destiny I'm not waiting on provision
from any Administration
I'm old Christy I mean I'm 62 years old
and I've lived through in my adult life
several several presidents who uh of
both parties who promised me Prosperity
so far none of them have provided it
not one and they won't every single
thing that has happened to Sharon and I
that's positive is due to God's
blessings and due to other people that
have helped us and due to our hard work
and Ingenuity and our refusal to quit
I agree you know you said a lot of
people you said you're not going to
reach Prosperity working on waiting on
the government and I think that more
than that I think there's some folks
that might feel like well this is my way
my ticket in I just feel like a lot of
people feel like the government owes
them something and they're sitting
around waiting and I'm not saying this
the case with Christy I don't know but a
lot of people feel like I'm entitled to
this the government owes me something
and and by God I'm gonna get what they
owe me and I just I have a hard time
with that I just it I'm over here and I
get angry Dave I'm not gonna lie I get
frustrated because I'm like there's no
such thing as a free lunch like this
this quote unquote forgiveness like
folks are paying for this and and folks
who've already paid off their student
loans are gonna if it if it goes through
I don't think it will but if it did
folks that paid off their loans are
going to pay for it folks that can't
afford you know
it's getting it'll be spread around
pharmacists that just paid off uh 200
000 worth of their student loans
are now going to have to pay off yeah
and here's the thing most of the people
that are getting this forgiveness I mean
we know what the the income uh bracket
was you can just afford to pay off your
loans just
pay off your loans there's dignity and
in doing work and paying your own bills
I just gotta say that Dave because it it
frustrates me when you can pay your own
bills that's called a blessing
when you can go through life and you
have the money because you've gone to
school or you've done whatever and and
you can pay your bill just pay them just
pay them you're going to feel great at
you're going to feel great about
yourself yeah
not sitting around waiting for the
government and again Christy I want you
to hear loud and clear we appreciate you
being a new listener and we're not it's
not you Christian and we're not picking
on your husband I'm not saying your
husband's a bad guy
um but you said what do we tell him I I
would challenge him as an old guy to say
I have
walking around experience proof and I've
got actual data
from the larger study of millionaires
ever done and none of those millionaires
said someone else
did this
um and unless they give credit to God
but I mean they they all here's what's
interesting when we ask them uh you who
you are who is responsible for your
wealth
97 of them said we did this
and and we said Can can it be done again
97 said it could be done again when we
interview the public that are not
millionaires only 69 said it can be done
wow and so what what you believe
about life affects your actions and your
actions create your Harvest your results
and so if you plant poison in fertile
soil you will grow Nightshade poison
which is a poison poisonous plant in the
same abundance that you can grow wheat
or corn in the same soil so what you sow
so shall ye reap what you pour into your
life your your belief when you put the
seed in the ground is your belief your
Harvest comes because you took action on
your belief yes and a hundred percent of
the time we all take actions on our
beliefs and so you have to be very
careful about your okay the action is
I'm going to wait on the government what
does that mean your belief is
it means that you don't think you can do
it on your own it means you think the
government is your best provision yeah
and that that is a that is a scary
belief because now we're talking about
socialism
well yeah on the political side you know
Karl Marx never made any millionaires
except him
that's what it comes down to uh under
communism there is an elite few that are
millionaires and they're all the people
that took it from everyone else none of
them were producers under capitalism The
Producers end up with things so all of
this to say Christie again this is just
us going off now just in general not
again not on your particular answer and
again I don't want you to take this as
condemnation like your husband's a bad
guy because we really don't think he's a
bad guy there's a lot of good people
that think this but what I would all
challenge all of you that think this is
be careful
about what actions you endorse because
that speaks very loudly what your
beliefs are it's going to tell you what
your Harvest is going to be
because what you plant a hundred percent
of the time is what comes out of the
ground 100 100 of what you plan in your
life comes up in your life
hundred percent of it good and bad and
ugly